in this video i want to talk to you
about how i made my first million
dollars in profit
mind you the reason i'm so big on profit
rather than revenue is that at that
point um i had already made you know i
was already making a couple million
dollars a year between all the different
things that i was doing but i was taking
home basically nothing
because i was so smart then i wasn't
paying attention to uh profit i was just
looking at revenue trying to beef myself
up and feel status rather than thinking
about what i was actually taking home
and um i told you in a different video
how i i got a head-on collision in a dui
at 60 miles an hour on the highway and
walked away from it and that was kind of
the catalyst that ended up changing my
life in a lot of ways mostly because i
decided to confront decisions that i had
been putting off
and make hard calls that i didn't want
to make to force myself to focus on one
thing
and so what i want to do in this video
is talk to you about the result of that
decision and um what kind of happened
and transpired in the next
six to 12 months which is anything
anything but a cinderella story i made
the calls i i went all in on gym launch
i basically fire sold my other
businesses and um just as a quick
tangent on that like a lot of times i
think the great thing that we have um is
sitting right in front of us after we
let go
of of the things that are holding us
down i'm a big believer in the theory of
constraint which is uh you know a system
will grow to to up to it's basically its
bottleneck right and then until you
relieve that like systems will grow as
long as they are not constrained and so
most of us are constrained in many ways
and we just do not recognize them which
is why we have things called limiting
beliefs it is a constraint right and for
me in a very real way i had constraints
in terms of um all the different things
that i was allocating my attention to i
had you know i think literally like nine
or ten business businesses i'll use
quotes here um that i was trying to run
at the same time and i was spread so
thin that i could barely allocate
anything and i was working every hour of
the day and i was drinking half a bottle
of johnny walker at night so i just go
to sleep and so anyways i i got in the
head on collision i uh i decided to make
the next uh the next move which was
going all in on gym launch and this is
uh the beginning of yet another hard
road ahead um and so at this time for
those who don't know i started flying
around and doing
uh done for you gym launches and so what
that was was basically layla and i would
go and do a gym turn around i didn't
like to use that word because i didn't
think gym owners liked it i was
originally going to call it gym rescue
um but no one wants to be rescued so i
called it jim launch and everyone was
okay with that name we would fly out uh
two brick and mortar facilities we'd sit
at the front desk i would spend my own
money on on on everything so the offer
was pretty simple i said i would fill
your gym in 30 days uh for free that was
that was the offer i was like i'll spend
my own money on the ads i'll spend my
own money on the hotels the food the
everything um and the deal is i just get
to keep the upfront cash that i collect
and then everything afterwards that's
contract value you get to keep it was a
pretty compelling offer right they
didn't have to do anything right they
would just say yes and then i would show
up
i think i'd ask for 500 to reserve the
date just to make sure that they
wouldn't like not be there but i i made
it a refundable deposit um but anyways i
would fly out and um
we would spend all the money in
marketing and we would sell on average
when layla and i would go we saw an
average about 200 people in 21 days so
he'd average about 10 sales a day
and then we would take you know then
we'd fly to the next one this is kind of
what we had been doing in 2016 and i was
doing this while also having six gyms
and two agencies and and and
all these other things that were going
on and i was spread wildly too thin and
that's when i got in the dui and then
decided to end everything except for gym
launch we ended up
basically
i i had to shut i had to i sold five of
the six gyms i shut down the two
agencies and then i had one gym that was
left over
and i put the money from the sale of
those other businesses which is not a
lot um into kind of the last facility
the the partner that i had at that
facility um ended up feeling like i had
been taking distributions
somehow from the business which i hadn't
and then he took what he believed was
rightful compensation for him
not being involved in that gym anyways
basically took the rest of the money out
of the account
and so i basically was left with nothing
so i was truly at this this you know
rock bottom moment of just gotten a dui
i just got rid of all my gyms i put all
the money from those gyms into this last
facility that money got taken
and i um
then decided to close that one gym down
and then when i did that i couldn't sell
any more at that facility to generate
cash flow because i wanted to close it
down i didn't want to be involved
in that gym anymore
and so i basically stomached rent and
payroll out of there with no new cash
flow coming in and i watched my bank
account basically go from some money to
no money
and so at the end of that we shut the
gym down i got tons of refunds and
things like that that ended up happening
afterwards because people
are weird when you when you shut a
business down so heads up and so we just
kept but the coach that i had at the
time was just like just write the checks
do right by everyone and you'll be able
to you know escape this thing um
unscathed emotionally and and more or
less i did i was able like that was some
of the best advice i ever got like i
just
i didn't try and pursue anything with
the partner i just wrote the checks for
all the the the customers who even if
even if we had fulfilled the services we
i just wrote the checks
and i actually didn't layla wrote the
checks because i was i was so like
destroyed by this entire decision you
know process but anyways i was
completely you know clean slate at that
point i think all in all um
i had twenty three thousand dollars left
over at that point
and so uh after after selling six
businesses and all the stuff i had like
nothing left and this was hard for me
because i just spent four years building
you know six facilities and all that
stuff and i almost had nothing to show
for it and that was one of the biggest
lessons that i've had is that like you
have all these skills and experiences
and character traits that you developed
to show for it like the entrepreneurial
journey is one that improves you not
anything else and so that's why i'm such
a big believer in that stuff because
like i had these things these assets
that i did not value
and what's crazy is that in the next you
know 30 days or so we did
a hundred something thousand in sales
and so i was like oh wow we uh we can do
this and so
anywho um actually i think what ended up
happening is i had almost no money and
then we did a launch and then i after
all the costs and everything i think i
had 20 something thousand um in in in
money for me the next month uh layla and
i said we were just focusing purely on
this business she told all of her
friends from high school to quit their
jobs right so she had
six friends from high school that all
were doing mlm shake mix stuff um and
she said hey you know you should quit
that and start selling this stuff we can
make 100 bucks a pop instead of you know
making five dollars on shake mix and
they were all like awesome let's do it
in between month between uh i think it
was like november-ish going into january
which is when we wanted to slate the six
gyms that we were gonna launch at the
same time which of course makes sense
right why go from one to two when you
could go from one to six because it's a
brilliant idea of alex's right and so we
had one month in between where i was
going to go launch a gym with layla we
were going to do like 100 grandish and
then i was going to be able to that was
kind of going to be the restart money
right so here's what happens next i get
a text from
a guy he's like hey my brother lives in
the same city as uh where you're
starting your new gym and i was like uh
not sorry doing a launch
i was like okay he's like yeah he's a
salesman he really needs a job um he's
got he's got a baby and he's got another
one on the way and um it might be a good
fit and so anyways i knew i needed to
take a month to kind of put all the
resources together to start doing the
launches at six at a time and training
the those sales guys and everything so i
was like okay that might might work
because then i don't have to spend all
day selling and so anyways i trained him
and he crushed it in the next 30 days he
did
um i think 120 000 in sales in december
which is like a hard month to do it in
and b it was a great first you know
launch for somebody who's new which also
kind of proved the model to me because i
had done it laila done it we never had
someone else who wasn't like
super tied to me doing it obviously was
more invested than just you know
just an employee right at the time and
so uh it was awesome so i was like super
excited i was like sick this hundred
grand is gonna be the launch money for
the next thing this will be great and so
um at this point layla says this guy's a
winner i'm gonna take him home to meet
my family which is hilarious because i
was not a winner at that time and so
anyways i'm at her at her family's house
christmas eve and we had been selling
for three weeks at this point so we had
you know 70 80 000 in sales at this
point and what was weird was i was
running all the the money through just
my gym processor because i still you
know maintain the processing uh like my
pos and um and so anyways i always got
deposits on tuesdays and i was like huh
this is weird we haven't gotten a
deposit since like i didn't get a
deposit last tuesday and i was like okay
that's odd and i call them and they're
like hey you know
i gave it like three or four days
because i was like you know maybe it's
delayed or something and it had been a
holiday because it was in the holiday
season whatever and so um the deposit's
supposed to hit it doesn't i wait some
days keep checking doesn't hit i call
them they say hey you're in an annual
review
it's standard nothing to worry about and
i was like that's weird i've been with
you guys for five years i've never had
an annual review
interesting
and then waited a couple days called
again was like hey man like we're really
gonna need these funds like i need you
to deposit these
um and they're like yeah it's we're
we're just working through some final
things blah blah blah i was like all
right and so christmas eve uh i call
them and uh we're supposed to launch six
gyms starting on the 26th so two days
later i called the guys up and i was
like i'm not getting off the phone until
you send me the money like i'm not like
i need there's a hundred grand that's
sitting there like i need that money the
guy was like
sorry you know we're seeing some regular
activity uh in your account and this is
because we had written all these refund
checks for for uh clients when i was
closing down the gym
the the last gym that i had so there's
been some regular activity this isn't
the way that um you know you're not you
it seems like you have a virtual
business now that's not what this is
intended for this is supposed to be for
a single brick-and-mortar location
so we're going to hold on to all the
funds for six months and i i lost i lost
it
um and for those who don't know me when
i lose it i don't actually get like
explosive i just get incredibly cold and
very mean and so i probably said some of
the meanest things like i didn't cuss i
was just like i destroyed the person's
character that i was talking to on the
phone like that person questioned like
why they were alive and so anyways i got
off the phone and uh
layla and i as parents are supposed to
go to the movies because it's it's
christmas eve and her dad was like you
know he seems a little stressed
[Music]
she's like is he always this way
and um and of course i was a little bit
stressed at that time um and so here's
what was crazy is that as we're going to
the movie theaters i'm just like
completely numb i just was like i feel
dead on the inside and so we go to the
theaters the movie's playing in front of
me i'm not even watching the movie layla
holds my hand and she's like what's
going on i was like i'll tell you later
she takes my pulse my resting pulse was
like 120 in a dark movie theater at age
27.
i was stressed out of my mind and so we
left the movies um and i told her i was
like the money's not coming and she was
like what do you mean i was like they're
keeping it she's like can they do that i
was like apparently like this is the
first time i'd even known this that a
processor can hold money and so anyways
i got home i still owed the salesman
from the last month who had done that
huge launch like this this all these
sales that had happened and somebody had
sold them right but i didn't collect the
money from it and so i owed a 22 000
commission check and i had 23 000 left
and it was on money that i never
received and so um
in in congruence with the the lesson
that i had learned from you know the the
clean exit of all these other things
which is like just do right by everyone
and then you won't have any emotional
scars that you'll carry with you and so
i wrote the check um actually i wired it
for 22 000 and i had a thousand dollars
left um and that's when we got home
and i told layla you know everything
that i'd done um i was like i have a
thousand dollars left and we were
supposed to launch she told her six
friends to quit their jobs um and we
were gonna start launching gyms two days
later on the 26th
um
and i was like i have a thousand dollars
and i have a credit card that has a
hundred thousand dollar limit i was like
i will do this i was like but this could
go horribly wrong
so you don't have to stay with me if you
don't want to
and um
that was like this was the moment for me
that i that i knew i was going to marry
layla and she said i would sleep with
you under a bridge if it came to that
she's like we'll get through it and that
was when i just like i wanted to like
you know i would i would have been teary
but i was so emotionally numb at this
point that i just wanted to just like
keep moving forward and keep keep keep
getting through it
and so anyways 48 hours later um i make
all the ads i set up all the campaigns
all the funnels all the everything's and
uh i remember turning the campaigns on
for all the six locations that we're
gonna do it's like off to on off to on
off on off to on
and i remember i was sweating i was
literally sweating when this was
happening because i just felt such dread
i was like this could literally just
ruin me like right now i have no money
but i'm i've never i'm not in debt um
and i'm going to be going in debt at a
at a rate of 3 300 per day of money that
i do not have and so anyways i turned it
on and the six guys were at the
locations i was and it was 3 300 a day
because i was paying for hotel airfare
food car
ad spend and commissions every single
day for six guys and i had remember i
had a thousand dollars
right and so it was all coming out of a
credit card
in the next 30 days um and we ended up
getting canceled by the processor right
i told you this at the beginning of the
story so i started all this and i had no
way to process money so these guys are
getting leads they're making calls
they're closing deals
and i can't process the money all right
and so
so we're sitting there right
and
and and these contracts are just coming
in right and we had them scan them so we
had this mobile app and we had this
central dropbox which of course is not
pci compliant i had no idea what pci
compliance was um and so we had this uh
one lady that we used to work fiji that
i was paying part-time to process this
mind you i didn't understand what like
how much work this was because we were
doing like 50 sales a day right um
between these locations at like 500
bucks a pop and i was paying someone for
part-time four hours a day of contract
work which was just insane it was like
it was probably two people's worth of
work and i was paying somebody part-time
it ended up that ended up blowing up
because she couldn't do that and her
full-time job so
and and we didn't even have a way to
process the money anyways right
and so anyways we're i'm calling
everybody i know to try and figure i was
like hey can you process this and then
you can keep 10 and just send me the
rest of the money and people were like i
don't know man like
i don't know if i want to do that and so
no one would process the money for me
and so um i called you know every person
i knew and then i finally got in touch
with a guy named alex roy at the time uh
who specialized in like high-risk
processing which is basically the
category i was in at that time and he
said i can get you set up and i was like
okay cool um he said but given the
record that you have right now because
you just refunded all those all those
people at the last okay she's like
they're gonna want a reserve which means
they keep a certain percentage no matter
what um and they're gonna put a limit on
how much you can you can you can charge
and i was like okay cool he said they'll
give you a 50 000 limit and i was like
dude
i i need like four times that and he was
like sorry man that's what i can get you
um and so the last week of january all
right so we were doing you know we're
doing five six you know thousand a day
um in sales maybe more than that
and i had no way of processing it right
and the last week i get this processor
for 50 000
and i run i run 50 000 in a day right
and uh he's like okay here's the good
news is that it's per month so it was
the end of he's like so this week you
can do 50 and then next week you can do
50. and then i'll see if i can get more
lined up more processors at 50k to allow
you to start processing for them and i
was like okay fine so next week we do 50
on that same processor and then we set
up another one um and another one
another one and i was able to like catch
this this falling plane as it's going um
and we ended up um somehow i think we
ended up processing 100 grand actually
that first one i think he got two people
he got somebody like the last day of the
month and i processed another hundred um
so another 50 to get 100 for that first
month and the next month i had three
processors so i was able to process 150
and things actually started uh
working out right so i you know we did a
hundred thousand which basically just
covered my credit card bill which is
doing 3 300 a day right so i just boom
i'm back to zero again but at least i
like had a way of getting out of this
thing right so the next month i think we
did 150 or 180 i have the the chart in
my book um 100 million offers uh i can't
remember what it was but it was
somewhere in there and so i processed
that february and we actually had a
profit that month so i was like holy cow
like we i think we made like 30 or 40
grand and i was like
oh my god i think we might we might get
out of this right but wait there's more
there's more to the story it gets worse
and so i think we're i think i'm in in
the home stretch right
and so then march rolls around all right
so at this point people that we had sold
in january um we we were selling
six-week weight loss programs at local
gyms
all of a sudden
i see this massive hit on the bank
account for a hundred grand and i was
like whoa what's going on what happened
and it turned out that two of the
facilities that we had launched in
january um and this is now at end of
february beginning of march um
they
told
a number of their
clients hey if you refund
you can just sign up through me
and i'll do it for less
and so we had already paid for the
airfare the flights hotels commissions
ad spend for all these sales so you know
the margin on this was lowish right i
was probably running 20 margins
and
uh that hundred thousand completely
wiped out all of the savings that i had
had over the next the last month or two
right um
and uh
and it was actually more than i could
even handle and so we had to sell more
to cover the refunds and so this is
where things got even more fun
and i say that sarcastically so this is
what happened next february we do more
money march i know that we have to sell
even more so i hired two more sales guys
we do eight launches that month and
that's to cover the refunds that are
starting to come in from january all
right
you can probably see where this is going
the refunds start getting worse there's
more and more and more it turns out
after everything 35
of all of our of all of our sales that
we were making we're getting refunded
which is an astronomical number that is
hard to even comprehend and it was
because we had no control over the
fulfillment right so we were selling and
then other people were filling on
contracts that we had sold and so and
there was a lot of you know hey just
refund sign up for me don't worry
because we'd be gone right we were
already we'd already left the location
and these people were getting fulfilled
on contracts and so we didn't have the
relationship with the customer the
business owner did and so it was a
really dumb model from that perspective
um i learned right one of the lessons i
learned there was control of like you
want to control everything end to end
if you want a life lesson
and so anyways the next month uh we're
we we have to sell more and so i think
we did 280 000 the next month and i was
like okay cool but all of the excess
cash that came from that from like the
profit went into funding these refunds
from the month before
and then refunds just kept going up and
so i knew that in april i was gonna have
to sell even more to cover the refunds
from february and march
and i felt like i was in a death trap i
was like i don't know how to get out of
this like every month i have to sell
more to cover the refunds from the month
before but then the cash from these
things somebody needed to cover the next
month and sell even more
and honestly i had no idea what i was
gonna do
and so um
all of a sudden uh leila at this point
because she still has one foot out the
door a little bit because she's like i
don't know about this guy um and so this
whole time she'd been living on like
three thousand dollars a month that she
was getting from her like online
coaching business so she had
transitioned her personal training
clients to online um and she was doing
like three grand a month from that and i
was like hey
why don't we take the middleman out of
this we know how to mark and sell weight
loss let's just sell it online which by
the way is a massive transition from
doing brick and mortar um but anyways i
was like you know i was in absolute
desperation
and so i wrote one of the best sales
pages of my entire life out of just
sheer need it took me two days to write
the sales the sales letter maybe three
and i didn't even like get up for the
computer i was just writing the sales
letter and so um
i started running traffic to it and we
started doing a thousand bucks a day um
of just online so there was no mard
there was no uh it was all margin right
minus ad spend and i was like holy cow
this could work right and so we had
eight sales guys since i was like okay
we can tell these guys they don't have
to sell gyms anymore they can sell from
home they can see their wives and we can
do 8 000 a day because if we're doing a
thousand just just with her selling we
could do 870 more guys and do 8 000 a
day
and so i told the guys the next month uh
the gyms that were lined up to launch
the next month hey we're not gonna we're
not gonna be doing this anymore sorry
we're gonna be going another direction
and they were like hey man like we need
this
and um i was like
sorry man like it's just it's just i'm
not doing that model anymore and um
they're like well can you show us what
you're doing because like my friend told
me that you signed up like 200 people at
his gym in like three weeks and i was
like
nah man sorry and uh he was like dude
please like and i was like i'm not
flying out there man i'm sorry i'm not
doing it um and so anyways push comes to
shove i was like fine i'll show you how
to do it i was like but i'm not flying
out there to save your ass you can't
sell he's like no no that's fine
he was like well how much to show me how
to do it and um at the time i picked
what was the highest number i could
possibly imagine in my head which was
six thousand dollars
and i said that because i didn't want
him to say yes
and um
because i didn't want to do it i just
wanted to move on because i was so
hopefully at this point you see how you
know scarred i was by all of these
experiences leading up to this um and
the guy said okay and i looked at the
phone and was like you got to be kidding
me
and i was like holy crap
and so it was six thousand dollars and
then i had seven more guys that i was
supposed to call you know to tell them
that i wasn't gonna do their launch the
next month
and so the next conversation i had i was
like well shoot if i'm gonna do it i
guess
i guess i have to make it now that i
sold one of them this whole program um
next guy same conversation with the same
way and he was like well how much i was
like eight grand he was like okay and i
was like holy cow
and then uh every single one after that
uh said yes and ended up doing sixty
thousand dollars in sales in a day and i
i looked at layla and i was like we
might be able to get out of this
and um at that time as much as people
talk about the romantic like vision and
strategy and and impact and saving lives
and all this stuff like
it wasn't any of that i was just trying
to be able to not be in debt and pay to
pay the bills that were mounting every
single month off and so i knew that i
needed to make like 150 000 in profit in
the next like 30 days or so in order for
this to work right and um this was the
only way i could do it and so what i did
was i i called you know those guys they
all bought and then i called up every
gym that we had launched at that point
which was like 32 i think and i called
every one of those guys was like hey you
know how we filled your gym up uh want
me to show you how i did that and they
were like yeah that would be great
that's exactly what we did and so i
ended up doing like 300 000 in sales the
next month selling a digital product
which was um actually more like a
consulting type thing
and here's what's crazy
the next 30 days
the average gym that used the consulting
program jim launch
did 30 000
in collected cash not contract not
contract not anything like that but 30
000
in sales in the next 30 days
and uh and then that is when everything
took off like a rocket because every
single one of those guys told every
person that they knew that was in the
gym space like dude i just did this
thing and it killed that was what gave
birth to jim launch as it became the
consulting company the licensing company
where we licensed out all the materials
all the ads all the copy all the scripts
how to set up the the lobbies and the
thing is is that when people ask me
about the story and this is you know now
we're six months into 2017 at this point
so i've gone through like the hardest 18
months of my entire life that is when we
just went from uh i think we did
a hundred grand that first you know
month or last last few weeks then we did
300 then 480 then 780 then a million
then one two then one five
one eight two two two like we just kept
we just grew like like a rocket and a
lot of people think it was because of
the marketing that i was running at that
point but it wasn't there was a lot of
it was just the word of mouth and the
actual product worked you know what i
mean um and i use that as an example
because like right now i launched the
book 100 million offers it's 99 cents
um with one post
on my instagram which is not that big um
of a following and right now it sells
about a thousand copies a day with no
funnels no ads no whatever um
and
it's because the product was good you
know i mean people talk if the product's
good and with this product i was able to
charge an egregious amount of money but
it was because we charged because we
were making people so much money like if
i if i gave you a system that made 30
000 on average in the first 30 days how
much is that system worth right most
guys charge you know for franchises
they'll charge 500 000 for a system that
does something like that right and i was
just charging 16 grand because i was
like holy cow like they're gonna make
double their money in the first 30 days
if they just do this right and i was so
i knew every aspect every piece of this
process because i had done it not only
for my six gyms but for the 30 plus that
we had launched and so like i knew the
differences between different markets i
knew how to train sales guys to get them
to do it i knew how to position the
offer i knew how to do the layout of the
sales room in the lobby so you could
maximize the amount of people that you
could sell i knew how to do the
nutrition consultations the next day so
you could cover all the ad spend um just
with product sales right like i knew all
these things because i did it
and so i tell this story to illustrate
one thing
one is that what you are going through
now doesn't mean like your work works on
you more than you work on it i was
developing skills character traits and
beliefs through this entire three four
five six year period of just of just
eating [ __ ] that i did not know was for
me
and so we think that the first business
the second business the fifth business
you start is going to be the business
that's going to be it for you but
like the journey is long you know what i
mean and you accumulate these skills and
these beliefs and these traits over time
and uh those become the things those are
your actual assets right the businesses
are just manifestations of those assets
in reality
and so
as a as as these things took off right
um
my you know my life radically
transformed uh
and the piece that i i get a lot of
questions about is like how can i do
what you did in my space or in my niche
or my whatever
and the thing is is people want to skip
the first five years of the story right
the first five years was that i i didn't
sell a question how to make ten thousand
dollars a month from a gym when i had my
first gym i didn't do that when i had a
second i didn't do that when i had a
third i didn't do that one out of fourth
i didn't do that when i had a fifth i
didn't do that when i had a sixth right
um because i didn't feel like i was good
enough and
it was only uh and even then i started
doing the launches as the next thing
because i wanted to make sure that
everyone always got way more value than
they paid me which was zero they paid me
nothing that i would fill their gym up
pretty good deal right no risk for them
and so i did that for almost two years
doing the doing the gym launches right
where we'd fly out and you already know
how that went which was difficult and
hard for me but i learned so much i
learned how to run a virtual sales team
i learned how to do all these things so
that when i did have the next
opportunity that lined up for me we went
from zero to 30 million in the next year
in revenue because i had accumulated all
of these skills in these character
traits that i would not otherwise have
had and so a lot of people want to just
jump to that part but they don't have
the skills they don't have the character
traits they don't have the beliefs that
align with what they want to achieve and
so i'm a big believer that the
foundation that you set is going to
dictate the height of the peak of the
pyramid that you want to build within
your life and the business that you want
to grow and so most people have a very
small foundation they took a course and
then they want to start selling how to
you know run facebook ads right
or whatever
and so the the reality is that they're
just not good enough and that's why the
thing that they have just doesn't work
that well which is why it doesn't make
money which is why they don't make money
right because the amount of money that
you'll be made that you'll make will be
will be will be predicted by the value
that you provide to the marketplace
that's always what it is i know this is
a longer story but i think that
hopefully it illustrates one that the
path is not straight uh two uh it is is
fraught with difficulty and and mind you
me telling you the very the quote end of
this story is that like oh yeah and then
you know everything took off like a
rocket
all of these types of problems there was
different problems that we had to solve
then which is like how do you double
every month
and somehow keep up with high quality
service and and support and and train
talent while also bringing new people in
and keep a culture um in all of these
things but at the end of the day the
product brought us so much forgiveness
from our customers because they were
just all making so much money um using
the systems that we had laid out that we
were able to build the infrastructure
as as the plane was flying uh
you know during the journey and so
anyways that was um that was the
transition of me going from broke and
looking up bankruptcy lawyers to uh we
did three million in profit just in the
last
like four or five months of that year
and then the next year we did 17 million
in profit um and that was because i
switched from a a service to uh to media
which has uh no cost of reproduction so
there's significantly higher gross
margins on it which is a better
opportunity vehicle and what's
interesting about this and i'll just
i'll i'll hit this because i can
probably make a video on this one
concept alone
but i think it's worth highlighting
is that when i had my gyms
right that i had relatively the same
skill set right i knew how to help
people lose weight i knew how to you
know i needed a market i knew how to
sell i had these locations all of that
from there i transitioned to a
done-for-you sales model right and i
made more money right now i had some
issues it's funny because i could look
at that model now and fix it in two
seconds because it's obvious what i
would need to do to change the model but
i didn't do that
but i made more money in terms of
revenue um and you know in terms of net
margins i was making more but there was
holes in the in the actual way the model
was designed which is why i had to do
with all these other things
and then finally we switched to
licensing um code and media right
and that is where you know the highest
gross margins exist and so i had the
same skills right um but as my beliefs
changed
and my character traits changed and
developed uh i was able to switch into
better and better opportunity vehicles
for the same set of skills and that is
what that was what ended up creating the
the fortune that layla and i were able
to you know amass in this period of time
um and it was because of of that
transition through different vehicles
repackaging the same skills and so the
first step in this is getting the skills
to to repackage and i think most people
just want to skip that part which is the
rocky cut scene that every single person
that i know is successful does that no
one wants to talk about every every
single
great big business owner that i know has
had these years of thankless work where
they develop these skills these traits
um in these beliefs that end up setting
them free and everyone wants to just
take the the one course and thinks
they're gonna become a millionaire in
six months and it's just not the case
and so um many people are far ahead of
me in their entrepreneurial journey you
know than i was in my first two years
three years five years and so i i tell
the story to hopefully give anyone hope
who's like two years in and isn't making
money it's like well multiply that by
three and then that's about where i was
where i started making real money so um
anyways lots of love mosey nation uh
love you all my name is alex for moses
i'm on acquisition.com we do about 85
million a year in revenue and i have
absolutely nothing to sell you um keep
being awesome if you did enjoy this hit
the subscribe button and i'll see you in
the next video and if you didn't like
this then i love you either way all
right lots of love i'll see you then bye